stories away for the game to take on a
greater meaning you play a single part
name and there's part of that experience
that you cannot get anywhere else grab
you the universe of titanfall 2 takes
place around five years after the events
of titanfall one among have actually
taken over twenty-five percent of the
frontier they're taking it back they're
taking a freedom back and in that
process the malicious discovered this
mysterious planet type in and they don't
really know what's going on there kuvan
bliss is actually back and he is working
for the IMC as a mercenary as a player
you'll have to face off a lot of
mercenary threats indigenous threats as
well as imc threats and if you can
survive that maybe you can save the
frontier
technically I'm not supposed to be
training you but in you I see potential
Jack Bauer is an enlisted rifleman who
wants to be a pilot at first he's
getting unofficially trained by his
mentor chapter lastimosa and we captain
lastimosa meets an untimely fate he
essentially says take the Titan finish
the mission that's a rifleman the lowest
of the militia being handed the most
advanced Titan in the frontier at first
be she was written in a way that felt
very bossy he wasn't always as much of a
personality as he is now he sees things
very literally you know almost like a
very grown-up toddler that's insane I'm
incapable of insanity pilot VT is very
carefully built to express we didn't
want it to be eyebrows you know like
really obvious surprise and anger but we
wanted something and just having a
little bit of blinking in there his eyes
are tracks with you and you kind of
looks at you and he emotes quite
interestingly focusing a little warmth
in his cold robotic pneus this Titan
weapon is an advanced design I think
somebody's in love the bond between Jack
and BTW was one of those aha moments in
development that relationship brought to
light the size of interdependence
between the two the previously wasn't
there definitely the big tool we lean on
to strengthen this bond is our
conversation system this is an
interesting way let the player speak to
bt and respond to the situation or not
if they choose our comp
but unfortunately my chassis will not
fit through the door lucky you I detect
sarcasm you get to engage with him and
learn a little bit more about how you
feel about him and how about he feels
about you and that evolves over the
course the game as the player proves
himself too BTW it's you against the
world with bt at your side it's good to
see you buddy it is good to see you too
pilot